all right we're back again hopefully it
stays
but you know i'm trying i'm trying to
stay zen about it it's [ __ ]
mysterious man
yesterday it went for like almost five
hours well wednesday we did a show and
it was like almost four hours long and
we didn't have a single problem
like wednesday night i don't know what
it is and like i said we thought that it
was just because it was high traffic
times like you know saturday night or
whatever
but then we would do some shows like in
the middle like on tuesday afternoon and
it would [ __ ] crash after 20 minutes
so i don't know it might be our wi-fi
connection it could be a lot of
different i don't know none of our smart
tv tvs have any problem
and we're on a lan not usually right
yeah i actually did even like buy
a buy a land cable so i couldn't because
i heard that was better like not to use
wi-fi so
it actually is hooked up right right to
the router i don't know what the problem
is
um so i don't know i don't think it cut
off too much
uh but i was basically saying that um
yeah so they knew pretty much like
between 8 and 8 15 that he had jumped
out of the plane
um because the plate the plane kind of
went to the like and like that little
light came on
so the plane lands at uh 10 15 pm
at reno airport which like i said that's
where they were supposed to land to
refuel um
and all the authorities were there the
[ __ ] fbi was there everybody
they weren't actually sure i mean
obviously the crew were like yeah we
think he probably jumped out i mean
because he
asked for the parachutes and the whole
thing with the tail of the plane
happened
but they weren't entirely sure so after
they landed like all the authorities
came on and they searched the entire
plane and saw that indeed he had
jumped out so during the investigation
the fbi uh takes a whole they found a
whole bunch of latent fingerprints
like inside the airliner now how many of
these belonged
to dan cooper no one really knows
they did no that wasn't his name well no
that's just what we're calling him
because that's what he called himself
that's what he called himself so we're
just assuming that's obviously not what
his name was
they also found um the the tie that he'd
been wearing the black tie which was
a good clip on ty because i guess he
couldn't be bothered like tying her real
time
so they found that and it had a tie clip
on it
and they also found two of the four
parachutes
that they had given him one of these
parachutes had been opened and
some of the lines had been cut out of it
they're not really sure they thought
that maybe he had kind of cannibalized
some of the
parachute like to wrap the money up
maybe because one of the um
crew members did say that they'd seen
him like tying something around his
waist they're assuming that he put the
money like in a
bag that he made and like tied it around
him to jump tied something to himself
and then there was another
then so there were two parachutes
missing
yeah that's odd how big was the bag of
money
do you know well let's see it was ten
thousand twenty dollar bills
so pro pretty big probably well not that
big i guess
he's kind of heavy he would have known
better he would have known better enough
not to put a parachute on a bag of money
and then throw it out
holding the rip cord that wouldn't work
no
see he must have just opened one
for some reason to make sure that it was
that it was that it was a real parachute
and then threw it out well yeah because
you'd think and
we'll get into this a little bit later
too but you would think and if he was
thinking
the reason they think that he ordered
four parachutes
was because he wanted the crew to think
that he was gonna take a hostage that
would jump with him
which would discourage the fbi from
giving him dummy parachutes
i don't think that's what it was
although i will say that they actually
did give him a dummy parachute
but they say accidentally yeah i don't
think one of the parachutes was it
i think he wanted four parachutes
because
i think he thought that they would
booby-trap all four of them yeah and he
would
open one up and find the booby trap
yeah okay and if he saw they were all
booby trapped
he'd go back and go okay you gave me
[ __ ] bum parachutes you [ __ ]
let's try this again yeah i mean four
parachutes they all have to be good
that's what he did yeah yeah no no he
was gonna take
didn't have anything to do with taking
hospital no i don't know no i don't
think he was going to take hostages i
think that he wanted them to
think that he was going to take hostage
so they wouldn't give him shitty bears
right that's that was part partially
what it was but then he he also wanted
to check
and that's what happened to one of them
which seems a very wise decision when
you're jumping out of a plane at 10 000
feet in the dark
so that means he was fully trained on
how to check your parents
how to [ __ ] um how to [ __ ] rap and
[ __ ]
what what what do they call it load up a
parachute yeah i've got
i forgot how it is pack a parachute he
knew how to pack it
so he opened one of them to make sure
that everything was good
and then he threw that out the reason
why i threw that out
he threw it out because he didn't want
the authorities to know that he had
checked
because he was going to do this again
see that's how well thought out he was
he didn't want the authorities to know
his mo
because he was going to do it again you
know maybe next year
well and we'll get into this too but one
of these suspects
later on uh did actually pull a heist
very very much like this so they don't
know if it was the same guy or if it was
a copycat but he did it almost exactly
the same
so we'll talk about it because he heard
about it probably well yeah but i'm just
saying that they don't know
so they're you know they're going to
think about that mr whoever d.b cooper
was he was the originator of all this
[ __ ] he [ __ ] had this [ __ ] all
figured out
and he was trying to cover his tracks at
the same time
he didn't want the authorities to know
that he opened a parachute to check
but they must have assumed that but it's
the same thing you would do it
because they left it on the plane the
opened one yeah
he left two of the two of them on the
plane one of them had been opened
even two on the but it looked yeah but
it looked like he had opened it
and like kind of cut so where are the
other two
he took him with when he jumped he took
one
he threw one out he put one on and
jumped with it
and then he cut another one open to get
some [ __ ] uh cords out of it
to help tie something to his waist yeah
tie the bag
yeah but one of them he just threw out
yeah maybe he threw it out because he
didn't want people to know that he
opened it up to check
yeah he just did not it's just something
you do in the military every military
guy knows what i'm saying
you just deny your enemy every scrap of
information you can that's what that's
they he's gonna he's thinking yeah they
would know that i would check them
but i'm not gonna i'm gonna leave them
in doubt you know
well the thing about dan cooper like i
said
it's even though he might have died
during the jump and i
kind of suspect he maybe did you you
can't deny
that he was he figured some [ __ ] out
like this was a pretty well planned
heist
and i will note that even if he did die
they still haven't found his ass and
they haven't
you know so obviously he did he did a
decent enough job that they never found
out who he was
there's two problems with this plan
though
there's a problem with everything yeah
first thing is
that it's a night jump on an unpropelled
unprepared lz in other words the landing
zone is not pre-prepared
yeah so he doesn't know where he's
[ __ ] landing yeah that's right to me
would be this guy
it's very [ __ ] dangerous okay the
other thing is
he's jumping from an aircraft that is
not designed for the jump
you can jump out and get caught up in an
eddy and [ __ ] bash your head onto the
[ __ ] part of that fuselage
and it could kill you and you never put
or knock you out and you never pull the
[ __ ] rip cord
well yeah see i mean things could go
wrong the reason that he picked that
particular boeing 2727 was because
out of all the commercial airliners it
was the easiest one to jump out of
without
doing without getting bashed in i mean
you still could but it was a lot less
likely like the way that the
you know where the stairs were situated
and whatnot so he actually
did know enough about the plane to pick
that one in particular
um be ju for that very reason because it
was the easiest to jump out of while it
was in the
telling you people something you know
i'm x airborne but i never jumped
not out of not not out of an aircraft
with a [ __ ] parachute
we would jump out of helicopters on a
[ __ ] on
repel lines all right that's what the
101st did
but i know enough about airborne
operations and jumping to know that it's
[ __ ] dangerous
it's dangerous even when you're doing
the right thing paratroopers get hurt
all the time
they make contact with something on
their way down
that's what that's the biggest [ __ ]
threat and usually they hit
and do something called a plf it's a way
of hitting the ground with your
feet then your knees and your thighs and
then your
[ __ ] hips and then your elbows on the
side
you're kind of using yourself as a shock
absorber when you hit
to absorb the impact because you're
you're coming down fast even though you
got to shoot on
you know well
most paratroopers [ __ ] lose their
careers doing that plf
uh something bad happens they hit they
hit something
that's on the ground where they can't do
the plf properly
in other words like they may be blown
into a tree or worst case scenario
something like a damn
metal bars or power lines there's all
kinds of bad things that could happen or
you come down you hit the trees and your
head hits a [ __ ] tree
you know i think uh i don't know we
might have some paratroopers in the
comment section i think
at the time of impact you're probably
going about 20
25 maybe 30 miles an hour that's a
significant [ __ ]
impact yeah hitting the ground at that
didn't sound very fast but hitting the
ground at that speed
yeah not so fun i mean [ __ ] man i hit
uh the rear of a car with my car going
maybe 25 30 miles an hour and the front
of my car would look like an
accordion yeah just goes to show it
doesn't seem fast but it is
something bad happened to me he he had
an impact with something either the
fuselage of the aircraft
or the tree or ground or water
and he drowned something like that it
kind of bums me out that he put so much
like thought and balls and [ __ ] into
this and then it just makes me sad to
think that he may be just like
smacking out of the plane or like
[ __ ] hit a tree or something jumped
out into the darkness that's a bummer
he jumped out into the darkness in a
desolate area not been able to see the
landing zone
on an unprepared landing zone which is
telling me right there in trees
trees that's what yeah and
that's [ __ ] very dangerous
and i mean it seems like if you were
gonna do this i mean yes it's much
harder to find you if you don't have a
pre-planned
landing zone yeah but on the other hand
if you don't have a pre-planned ladies
it's like you bland in the middle of the
[ __ ] forest
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do you don't
wanna be food or water you're not
dressed for the weather
you you know you don't have anybody to
pick you up it's like you're just like
wandering around in the [ __ ] woods
and you don't know exactly where you are
well you walk in any you walk in any
direction long enough in the united
states you hit a road
that's true maybe he just was like yeah
i'll figure it out when i get down here
i think he kind of had an idea of more
or less where he was
uh but he just jumped off into the
darkness and landed into a bunch of
trees
and got tangled up maybe broke his back
on some limbs
anything could have happened or he cut
himself free from the tree and then fell
30 feet and [ __ ] broke his back
we broke his leg and was able to walk
out there's a lot of bad things that
could happen
or he lands into the damn water and he's
wet
he walks around for a little bit and it
was cold that was late november he walks
around for a little bit he died
hypothermia there's a lot of bad things
that could happen he didn't think
certain things through evidently he
thought about
the heist but not how to extract himself
in out of the lz which kind of seems
like the most important element
i mean i would think well it might not
have been his main plan
maybe his main plan was to go to mexico
city
and this was more like his back or plan
c
yeah may have been something like he's
like [ __ ] it i'm just going to jump out
i'm going to jump out and take my chance
maybe before he jumped he's going well
over in that direction i see some lights
i'll just walk in that direction
once i hit yeah maybe he was planning to
go to mexico city because he did seem
very specific that he wanted the plane
to go to mexico city
and he even like agreed hey yeah we're
gonna stop arena to refuel and
everything
so then for him to just like jump out
yeah this might have been
a random play it might have been plan b
or plan c
yeah that's yeah i i could see that he's
just kind of like well that's
abort that mission right and then he's
probably looking out and he's like i see
a city over there this would be a good
place to jump and he just opened the
thing and
on his way down he's looking he goes
okay it's over there it's over there and
they pulled the [ __ ] rip cord and
went in some trees and somehow didn't
make it
yeah yeah um let's see all right so
uh as i said so the fbi was
investigating they had a bunch of
fingerprints
weren't really sure which of them
belonged to the you know hijacker
obviously
um but a couple of the crew members i
mean they had
spent a great deal of time with him so
they were able to give really really
good descriptions
and actually the two crew members the
two uh flight attendants
that had uh talked to him they gave
uh separate accounts of what he looked
like like they were even in different
cities and everything like when they did
that like then they sat with a sketch
artist
and the sketches that they like looked
almost exactly the same so they're
pretty confident that that was exactly
what it did look like
now when they first started
investigating this the cops and the fbi
and everything like that they had
like [ __ ] 800 suspects
for this [ __ ] like to start and even
nowadays i think there's still
maybe a thousand or some [ __ ] like that
not all of them are super serious
but so they were looking at like you
know between 800 and a thousand people
they were able to winnow this down to
about
24-25 people that were a lot more
serious contenders
now as i mentioned at the beginning of
the show even though the dude
gave his name as dan cooper it's right
there on his plane ticket you can see a
picture of it
um there was a like a newspaper writer
and i guess he mixed up
the name of the hijacker or the
pseudonym that the hijacker gave
with a dude named d.b cooper who was one
of the early suspects who was later
dismissed of the charge
you know they were kind of like yeah it
wasn't him so this
newspaper reporter was like in a rush i
guess he had a deadline or something and
so he like confused the two names
and for whatever reason i guess because
db cooper sounds a lot more
distinctive than dan cooper so now
everybody knows him as db cooper even
though that's not the name that he gave
so
i just thought that was like really
funny and it was just like one newspaper
article and somebody
everybody just picked it up and ran with
it i don't really know it's cool it
that's what i'm saying it does sound a
lot cooler than just
dan cooper you know dan cooper just
sounds like a kind of a generic name
just anybody yeah
so um so as i said there they weren't
really sure
obviously they're going to start looking
around on the ground where they think he
might have landed
and they actually did a good job trying
to triangulate
where his landing zone might have been
however
there were a lot of factors that
made that task a lot more difficult
uh they're pretty much well they're like
it's a massive area to search and it was
kind of a lot of it was kind of remote
they're like you know we weren't sure
exactly what altitude the plane was at
we weren't sure
thank you trevor gotta head out but look
forward to picking this back up later
but man said i should leave a super chat
man that i could yeah yeah that's like
the best [ __ ] excuse for everything
just excuse for anything
said i could oh okay fair enough yeah
but yeah so uh so they're just like okay
so we weren't sure exactly like what the
uh
altitude was exactly you know they knew
pretty much when he jumped out but not
exactly when
they're like how long did he fall before
he pulled the rip cord if indeed he did
pull the rip cord
so the thing about it like they you know
as i mentioned the two
uh they had the two air force pilots
that were following the
you know the commercial airliner and um
they said they didn't see anybody jump
out but like i said the visibility that
night was really really shitty
like it was kind of storming it was
really cold it was really really dark
out
um so they didn't see him jump out of
the plane no visual they didn't have
anything on radar
so they weren't exactly sure you know so
so like i said the area where he
potentially could have landed was
massive brad jones says yeah but there'd
be a white parachute you could find
no it's not that easy if he makes it
down in between the trees
the trees then obscure the parachute
even if he's dead
if he's alive if he makes it alive
his standard thing to do would be to
collect the parachute bump bundle it up
into a ball and kind of bury it so you
can't see it
that's the same thing a soldier does you
don't leave the parachute just sitting
there
you take it you hide it
but uh no no it'd be it'd be
it's harder to think it's harder to find
than you would think you'd have to look
directly at it
and from a high altitude you wouldn't
see it
yeah and this is like a massive area and
it's a pretty wooded
area too where they think that he might
have jumped out it
could be sitting on top of a tree
partially with him hanging dead
and if you weren't low enough you
wouldn't see it yeah
like you know trying to find somebody uh
out in the ocean you know it's a lot
harder than you think
and you're looking at the surface of the
ocean and you can't see them well yeah
[ __ ] man there's like whole [ __ ]
ships that have gone down
they still haven't found nowadays like
from hundreds of years ago we're
talking about somebody on the surface
center in a dinghy you know a helicopter
has to
fly right over and they don't see them
yeah because they're they're at a high
altitude so he's
a tiny little dot
mango says db cooper is bigfoot
oh my god somebody needs to write that
movie i'm sure someone already has
someone at the sci-fi channel
but uh one thing that they did i thought
this was really interesting the fbi
actually did a recreation and they got
the same pilot the same plane or the
same type of plane
and they went up to the same altitude
same speed everything
same flight path and they had a look
like kind of a sled or something like
that that weighed
approximately what db cooper weighed and
they pushed it on the back of the plane
because they wanted to see where it
landed
you know what i mean so they were
actually able to and they and they were
trying to figure out too like what time
they think he jumped out
so they think it was about 8 13 p.m so
that kind of helped them like narrow
down the time
which you know maybe made them have like
a smaller area that they had to search
for this dude whether it was a body or
whatever
so from the initial kind of
investigation they thought that
he had probably landed somewhere right
around like
uh on the southern side of mount saint
helens
um near ariel washington
now so they start like looking all these
and it's like wilderness like i said and
they also went around there's some farm
houses and [ __ ] like that out there
and they went house to house and asked
if anybody had seen him
they ran like a whole bunch of patrol
boats you know to
in the reservoir nearby and all this
other [ __ ] they found
nothing they have no sign of him nothing
from the aircraft
nothing they also did um you know a
whole bunch of aerial searches they had
helicopters they
have all kind of [ __ ] they did find
something
they found some broken tree tops looking
things and they found some kind of
plastic
pieces and maybe something that might
have been part of a parachute but it
wasn't definitive
um and i guess after a while they
decided that that didn't have anything
to do with anything it was just like
some random [ __ ]
so again they found nothing there you
guys gotta imagine this
you come down the middle of the night
even if you you walk around even if you
make the landing
you walk around for how long until you
find a road
all right then you find a road and
follow the road
what happens when you are on the road
eventually somebody in the car might
drive by
or the road takes you to a place like a
gas station or a town
how do you make contact with somebody
there to get out of there you're gonna
have to approach people hey i need a
ride can you hire
you know can you call me a cab or can uh
can you take me to the bus station or
i'll give you ten thousand dollars to
take me somewhere
he's gonna cause he's gonna call too
much of attention to himself
you're gonna see this dude yeah well
i will get into something later on where
somebody claimed that exactly that
that happened that happened but um and
it can it only came out like a couple
years ago
okay so we'll kind of get into that yeah
you'd have to bribe
somebody on the road to take you
somewhere yeah
and uh that that's that's risky
as a robber it is because you don't
really because you're gonna be all over
the [ __ ] news
probably you're trusting your life to
this stranger
he said yeah i'll take the money yeah
takes it to the cops yeah
or something or tells the cops yeah you
don't know
you know you don't if you were if you
were
planning this mission you wouldn't want
to leave anything to chance
yeah and i think he planned it pretty
well
dealing with the airlines and and
dealing with the police and jumping out
but
his plan to extract himself from the lz
is not very good it's weak
that's what i was thinking like i said
it's you know it seemed like he planned
the rest of it so carefully and then
this was just kind of like [ __ ] it
i'm just gonna jump out wherever i'm not
even planning it'll be fine
i think he planned to jump out somewhere
near mexico city in a [ __ ] crowded
area
where it'd be easy for him to get catch
uh catch a mexican cab
to some kind of a damn hotel
i mean i would have thought if you like
something yeah if you were going to pull
this off like
fly to a country where there's no
extradition treaty it seems like the
safest move
and somewhere where you're kind of
familiar with i guess
um brad asked how in uh how and when did
you
serve when and when and where did you
serve me
yeah yeah 90 to 94 us army
11 bravo i was in uh camp grieves and i
was at
um in camp greeves korea with the uh
second id when the when the 506 was
established
attached to them and then uh i was at
four campbell
from fort campbell got deployed to uh to
sinai egypt
and then uh got out in 94.
okay good uh brian also asked has there
been a movie made about this i don't
know if there was a movie i mean this
it's it was on unsolved mysteries
there's been like a whole bunch of
documentaries made about i think there
have been like a couple of movies
somebody mentioned uh without a paddle
that maybe had been like kind of loosely
based on it
i don't know if there's been like a
factual movie made about it it seems
like it comes up on a lot of
crime shows and
oh thank you thank you so much jennifer
in canada that's my name too jennifer
not canada so uh
all right so they they found like no um
you know in in the place where they
thought he might have landed they didn't
find any evidence to suggest where he
had gone they didn't find a body they
didn't find anything from the plane they
didn't find anything
so um so after [ __ ] thought out
in 1972 which is always funny to me
because i grew up in florida and we
don't have nothing freezes here so
it's it's funny to me that it's like out
here about eight years ago yeah but it's
like it's like yeah we gotta wait until
like
a few months until all the [ __ ]
frozen [ __ ] thoughts out before we can
look for any missing people
that's crazy because like i said that
doesn't happen here so it's like i don't
know it's funny
but uh so yeah so everything thought out
in 1972 so then they sent out a whole
bunch of other
uh you know they had like [ __ ]
soldiers and air force people they had
all kind of volunteers
and they spent like months and months
and months
looking for not only they dredged all
the lakes they'd like [ __ ] look
through all the woods and everything
like that
they didn't find anything how well okay
they define one thing
they found a skeleton in clark county
these two women found it however this
skeleton
after they did forensics on it turned
out to be
a murder victim barbara ann berry she
was a teenage girl
who had been abducted and murdered so
they found her so that's good
but they didn't find uh they didn't find
her i mean it's not good she got
abducted and murdered obviously but it's
good that they found her body
um accidentally while they were looking
for db cooper
so uh but they found jack and [ __ ]
they found nothing so at this stage the
fbi
as i said they had taken kind of
microfilm pictures of every single bill
that they had given to him and
they started giving lists of all the
serial numbers of all the bills
to i mean they they released them to the
public at one point but
i think at this point they had like all
these businesses and casinos and [ __ ]
like that and they just gave them a list
and they said if any of these come up
you know call us immediately because
somebody's spending this money
so that's so that's what they did so
we're going to track them like i said
that was like just like the lindbergh
kidnapping if you know anything about
that
uh you know they track the um you know
the serial numbers on the money
so basically the airline uh decides
they're gonna offer
25 000 reward uh if anybody brings in
some of the recovered money
like you know that leads to his capture
whatever um
and like i said a little bit later that
year they released all the serial
numbers to
the public and uh
you know the just encouraged everybody
hey look at your money
they i even remember like uh seeing
pictures
on the internet of like you know big
billboards and stuff hey look at all
your 20
bills and see if you have any of these
uh you know
if you have any serial numbers because
they'll give you like reward money
now 1972 obviously someone's going to
take advantage of this so you get to
like two con men
and they counterfeited some 20 bills
with those serial numbers on them and
then they went to
a reporter for newsweek and they were
just like hey these are the
we we found some of these [ __ ] uh db
cooper money and like give us thirty
thousand dollars like for an interview
so they like scanned like those scammed
thirty thousand dollars out of this guy
because one of them said that he was db
cooper but it wasn't
so uh at this point like 19
a year goes by 1973 early in the year
uh no one's found any the ransom money
none of these serial numbers have turned
up
so you know pretty much they release
re-release this [ __ ] to the public
you know tell everybody to look at their
money gave everybody a bunch of rewards
[ __ ] like that and then you know it just
kind of went on and on no one found
anything
now i'll get into a little bit later on
because some of the money was found
later on but i'll get into that a little
bit later
so as i as i mentioned they
kind of they had triangulated the one
place where it was most likely that
uh you know it was in a large area where
db cooper probably landed however
when they kind of looked into it more
like a little bit later on like in
kind of the mid 70s they're like okay
well maybe that was
inaccurate um
he's like because the pilot i guess that
he thought
that his flight path was farther east
than it actually was so they kind of got
together with a bunch of other experts
and [ __ ] like that and they kind of
found out
okay well maybe you know he didn't jump
out
over here it's like you know they were
trying to figure out the wind direction
and everything
so it's like actually where he probably
jumped out of the plane uh was actually
a lot more south southeast
of where they thought it was initially
and they think that this was maybe
around
the and i hope i'm pronouncing this
right the washougal river
so um so yeah they think that maybe
he jumped out around there now as i
mentioned earlier
uh the fbi is no longer this is no
longer an active
investigation as of 2016 but if you
still have veterans they're still
accepting it because like i said statute
of limitations
has not gone out so
um basically let's get into
what physical evidence they had because
they do actually have some dna evidence
and we'll get into that a little bit
later too
the very famous sketches of db cooper
which are considered very reliable
because the crew members that gave them
gave them separately and uh you know
they had spent several hours with them
so they were like pretty sure that they
knew what he looked like
um they thought that he was about five
foot
ten inches tall weighed about 180 pounds
uh probably in his mid-40s or looked in
his mid-40s
had swarthy skin so he was kind of a
little bit
dark-skinned still a white person but a
little bit dark-skinned and close-set
piercing brown eyes she just showed up
oh hey
what's up t yeah and um let me see uh
mango said uh they did a movie called uh
pursuit of d.b cooper in 1981 and then
michael schaefer came in and said uh
yeah he did
search up did a [ __ ] episode too yeah
i thought they had that in search of
episode was the [ __ ]
i need to watch that again i should have
watched it for this i watched the
unsolved mysteries but there's something
creepy about
[ __ ] in search of i've tried to watch
some of it on some of the older ones on
youtube
and the transfer isn't very good imagine
if they came out with a dvd or blu-ray
version of [ __ ]
maybe eventually they will if there's
like enough because i mean look what
they did with unsolved mysteries it's
like you know they recently just
released all they have their own youtube
channel now where they put all the
[ __ ] episodes on there
yeah a lot of money to be made of course
they should have done this
nostalgia man all right i mean they
should totally [ __ ]
but i'd like to clean that [ __ ] up they
have like a really good copies
of the entire search of series
i could listen i could listen listen to
leonard damoid like talking about
anything
made everything sound creepy he did kind
of like orson welles made everything
sound like important yeah yeah even if
it was
nostradamus yeah the great king of
terror was coming
how he even like got through that entire
commercial
the people that shot that commercial
must have been like god damn it orson
this took like five days it should have
taken like three hours
i'm glad that would that we were around
to to in the right time to understand
that era
because that era is now long gone and it
will probably never return
everyone's era is long gone eventually
yeah you know
that era was that you had some dudes
that could just seem
important yeah all you had to do you
just had to say some [ __ ]
it was kind of a gravelly voice you had
some conviction
yeah you could say whatever crazy
[ __ ] you wanted to say and people be
like yeah i suppose
you'd even watch the academy awards i
think what it was it's because you
didn't see celebrities that often
you only saw only had a few channels
yeah you're just like [ __ ]
you get a [ __ ] out of here they're
all on instagram and you know who they
are why am i seeing your face everywhere
yeah
all the mystique is gone you know what i
mean you it was like yeah there's no
mystery
yeah it was like a rare occurrence to
see a celebrity
that you liked because they were trying
to fight over air time
just in a couple different channels and
everything was canned canned is [ __ ]
you know nothing was [ __ ] realistic
nothing was
like it was in real life it was just a
world of fantasy
so you didn't really know who the people
were so you could blow them up into
something that they weren't
yeah because they seemed like greater
than greater than they actually were
sure because when you see [ __ ] orson
welles
in the outtakes of him making those
palma saw and wine commercials that
[ __ ] was loaded
loaded and [ __ ] [ __ ] up [ __ ] it up
every few minutes
so it was like it was that level that
dude made me seem intelligent
well that's the thing i do kind of feel
like you didn't get
a lot of i mean it's not like nowadays
like you said where
everybody's filming everybody so people
just show their ass at like every
opportunity because
which in a way i kind of like that
better because you're having
no illusions yeah you're not like
building up this weird
you know thing around a person i kind of
lived in a world of fantasy in a way
back then
like for instance like i was big i was a
big fan of billy idol but you rarely
ever saw him maybe he show up on [ __ ]
david letterman you stay up all night to
[ __ ] oh man
billy idol's gonna be on david letterman
you see him for a few minutes and he's
gone
yeah and it's not like that [ __ ] was
recorded and you can say play that back
play it again you couldn't play it again
yeah you know
it's not like you say i want to hear all
of billy idol's [ __ ]
interviews from everywhere in the world
in the past [ __ ] five years
that's youtube television wasn't like
that you just had to guess what was
going on
yeah you missed it you were kind of i
missed it it was over yeah yeah it was a
different era
i don't know i'm conflicted because like
i said it is kind of nice
that you know uh the people still had
some mystery about them
yeah but i don't know in some ways i
think that that's kind of unhealthy
because you're seeing them as like not
the same species as you
well what's what was weird is that you
kind of assumed that they had it a lot
better than you and they were [ __ ]
better at [ __ ] than you were
and [ __ ] that their life was more
exciting than yours
and in some ways maybe it would have
been because they were going to better
parties and [ __ ] but they would make
more money but they weren't that they
had more money than you but they weren't
that different from you
you know everyone's a huge they got to
take a [ __ ] just like everyone else and
if you spent a couple of days with them
you'd get sick of them
yeah and they probably had super
annoying like [ __ ] personality quirks
just like everyone does
so then you'd be like oh man you were
only seeing them at their best
that's the thing well why do you think
that tabloids and [ __ ] like that
do such a brisk business in pictures of
celebrities without their makeup we just
saw him going out to get cat litter or
something like that and they didn't
bother putting makeup on they're just
out there and [ __ ] sweatpants
and i'm just like can you imagine i
can't imagine i don't even know
dude i'm not even famous and i don't
even like to go to the grocery store
without makeup on okay
so i can't imagine like being super
famous like being somebody like [ __ ]
angelina jolie or whatever
and then you know you you just are known
for looking like [ __ ] beautiful all
the time and then it's like dude i just
gotta run up and
get some [ __ ] you know pepperoni or
something like that and then like
paparazzi or they're like taking [ __ ]
pictures of you looking like
you know hammered crap and then it's uh
suddenly it's all over the front of the
national enquirer you just looking like
not even
like you yeah you know what i'm saying t
is tripping out yes
yes that uh the outtakes from the paul
busan
why that's where i saw that um
then she goes lantern yeah it's [ __ ]
great
um poor hearts then t is also having a
uh
a sexually charged reaction to the
mention of leonard nimoy
yeah i tell you i kind of have that too
i mean you know look at like
i got that life-sized spock back here
see here's the thing i like good spock
that boats box are goods box
so soap is also in the comments right
now and [ __ ] i got soap onto the star
trek the original series
and you know she's she's a youngster
from our point of view and she'd never
seen those and she's going through this
old
comfort television and she was like
appreciating how good [ __ ] star trek
was
and she started to develop a damn crush
on [ __ ] spock
how can you not and here's the thing man
here was the story behind this when they
first started making that
series they kind of cast
kirk as being kind of like the dashing
romantic
lead of the [ __ ] series
but they were doing market research like
they did back then because
experts ran [ __ ] back then not children
they've tried to find out what the
audience liked
and they found out that single dudes
liked kirk but women married women and
single women
had this thing for [ __ ] spock duh
right
so what they started to do later on in
this scenario was call me
they started to write spock in
to [ __ ] romantic [ __ ] situations
in the [ __ ] series where he's trying
to resist
he's trying to resist these women ain't
that some [ __ ]
because women have this fetish of trying
to go after a dude who's saying no
that he's i'm too logical for this no we
we cannot be together oh no it's [ __ ]
you could do
now that [ __ ] started with [ __ ] nurse
chapel there's chapel
about it is that here's a dude you don't
want somebody that's like just
completely indifferent to you
yeah um you don't want that like they
don't give a [ __ ]
you want somebody that you know they
give a [ __ ] deep down but they're trying
they're trying so hard to resist it
because it's like you're only you're
too much for me women find that very
very appealing
they don't like dudes that are just kind
of like no i don't give a [ __ ] about you
at all that's not
that's not the same and spock had that
uh forbidden fruit
aspect to him that too where he was
something it was a trans
it was a trans species or an
inter-species relationship
you really weren't supposed to be hidden
that that wasn't human
see that was part of it too so
i don't have a problem women like all
that kind of slight [ __ ]
kink you know it's like a kink thing you
know well [ __ ] man even nowadays what do
you think i don't know if it's the
largest but it's definitely one of the
largest uh segments of
uh written erotica which is 80 90
percent
women uh purchasing that is um
like werewolf [ __ ] like where creatures
werewolves and [ __ ]
vampires like beasts and then women
having sex with beasts
yeah what it is i mean not beasts but
like human beings humanoid [ __ ]
sure and like where white lives yeah
that is a
massive massive market now growing up
partially in brazil i look at the spot
character and to me
it's just the foreign guy syndrome and
it's absolutely true
if you're cute and you're foreign you
just get it
and if you have money you just get all
the girls well there's a that
exoticism yeah yeah they have brazilian
dudes trying to kill my ass over this i
was taking their girlfriends
yeah because you were americans i was
american i had money and if i had a car
and
i was looking good and [ __ ] you know
i was a teenager so i just i can get
everybody's [ __ ] girlfriend
you know i was competing against other
teenagers you know not
married dudes you know or married people
but yeah i was like yeah i don't get all
the [ __ ] girls i just show up in the
[ __ ] brand new little [ __ ] vw bug
and pick up the girl
those guys i hate that [ __ ] i
gotta kill that [ __ ] yeah i took
your girlfriend [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm an american yeah dang i'm dropping
my nuts right well that wasn't it wasn't
that
it wasn't that i spoke fluent portuguese
and everything it's just being foreign
well yeah had i been french it had been
the same way yeah had i been any other
you know yeah you're not from you're not
from there
and that's that's that's really you know
women love that but i think guys do too
the foreign girl
well like i said it's just kind of like
you grow up around people it's like you
don't necessarily want to like
marry the people you grow up around
because it's like yeah you're kind of
sick of them yeah
you know so it's just kind of like this
exotic they don't have to be that exotic
they're just
like from another state or whatever and
they just turn up and it's like they
have some different [ __ ] going on and
it's like oh this is intriguing
you're not like all the losers around
here you know what i mean
familiarity breeds contempt right it's
so
if you've grown up around people your
whole life and you're just used to
people being one way and then somebody
turns up it's a little bit different
that's like really intriguing
tina said spock should have been the
kiss of the horror not kurt
ooh i don't know i don't know i don't
know i like it i like it
see they were built although in the new
movies they set the two of them up as a
couple and i kind of dug that
they were actually on some of those
episodes trying to build something up
between ahura
and [ __ ] kirk because remember
[ __ ] her would say some [ __ ] like
you know i feel i feel much more brave
when i hear your voice and all that kind
of [ __ ] you know
she having him at the helm and [ __ ] she
was she was [ __ ]
she was crushing on him but she was
professional she was trying to
and evidently they were insinuating
those same episodes that [ __ ] kirk
liked her but he couldn't
show any emotion towards her because she
was on the bridge she was like close
bridge
[ __ ] you know what i mean now well yeah
everyone's maintaining but you know
i don't understand that there's not a
lot of continuity between all those
episodes they're written by different
people
they were writing them as they were
going so some people wanted to push it
into one direction and then another
somebody else would like push it into
another they're they're they were meant
to be standalones
they're which they are i mean it's
better to watch them like when you get a
context of all the characters but i
think the reason why that
um that series still works after all
this time
is because of the characters and because
of the interaction particularly between
you know kirk and spock and bones and i
think that's kind of like the heart of
the show so then they can just kind of
put them in any situation
and even any writer that comes in it's
like well generally we know that kirk is
going to do this and spock is going to
do this and bones is going to do this
so that's kind of like where the
conflict comes from so as long as as
long as you kind of keep to those
parameters it's still going to be good
and it's not going to be like too
[ __ ] out there you know what i mean
so chimes in she says i'm more partial
to kirk actually
the spock is great too ultimately it's
all the writing the banter between the
two is my favorite part of the show
yeah yeah kirk is the three of them the
bromance
with with bones and stuff like that
thrown in there too because i love him
because he's so like crotchety i love
that
it was a tri-sexual bromance i know
that's my favorite safety
yeah yeah that's something that can't be
replicated because
that's not just the writing although it
is that but it's also the actors
um you can't it's really really hard to
replicate that with different people
because it was just the three of them he
comes back and said for me
just seemed like the i'm so in control
of his emotions unlike kirk that kind of
drives me up the wall very sexy yeah
that's what that's that's what jenny
thinks too because the thing about spock
is that he doesn't he's not a sociopath
he doesn't have no emotions it's not
like ted bundy or anything like that
the whole vulcan thing is that their
emotions were so overwhelming
that they had to learn to control them
otherwise they'd just be like flipping
their [ __ ] all the time right
so there's something like really
appealing about that is you know he's
just like a cauldron of seething
emotions like underneath but he's like
keeping it all under control
brad but any minute he could like bust
out brad jones says i'm getting my t
levels checked next week thanks tom
that's right get that [ __ ] checked
i [ __ ] called my boy well everyone's
dead everyone should if you're a man
after the age of 35 you're going to
start feeling like not really all that
great
40 i felt great i felt great until i was
about 47
and then i just started not feel quite
right
feel like you're going away like the
[ __ ] hand of death is coming after
you
go get that [ __ ] checked because that's
that's it yeah he started telling me
that all this oh man i think i'm dying
death is coming my end is coming i just
felt the shadow of death [ __ ] cast
over me
it's just because your hormonal levels
have dropped
that's what it is well why do you think
i kept like [ __ ] i knew something was
wrong i had to [ __ ] check in the edge it
was wrong yeah i was like looking
dude you're not dying i got the results
like you could live another like [ __ ]
30 years
i felt like i was dying crazy it feels
like
you're the elixir of life is being
drained from you and in a way it is
in the way it is i haven't just drained
one year of your life away if you ever
saw a movie called the fiendish plot
of dr fullman he was trying to make the
elixir of
okay so he could go out and [ __ ] you
know and be the man he was
that's that's [ __ ] trt that's what
that is
i was listening to these guys talking
about a guy they're full of [ __ ] but
then the more i started hearing about
what they were talking about is he added
something to that
i started to study the androgen system
went and had that [ __ ] checked and sure
enough
bing my [ __ ] came back like a [ __ ] 80
year old man
that's how low my left yeah it was way
low way low
i was even surprised yeah that's why i
felt like i was dying
well that explains it and what kicked it
off is watching my dad almost die
yeah because depression starts a [ __ ]
cycle of it
you depress you're depressed so your
testosterone level
declines and then you feel bad so you
feel more depressed and it declines more
that's what happened to elvis man as
soon as he got about as soon as he lost
his career at 35
i think it was all this peanut butter
peanut butter nana sandwiches that's a
lot of dudes you know what i mean [ __ ]
it happens to dudes coming out of combat
they're living up high
on adrenaline and feeling great and they
go back to flipping burgers and
mcdonald's
fall apart i think it's
you know it's maybe and i'm not saying
like because you know women have their
own issues but
i think it's better than it used to be i
will say back in the old days i do feel
like men really defined themselves
too much in my opinion by their careers
and by what they did when they were
young it's the self-esteem yeah yeah so
uh you know
you used to see it like a lot back in
the old days like as soon as a dude
would retire when he was like 55 or 60
or whatever like a couple years later be
dead because
he didn't have that purpose anymore and
he felt like he was useless
yeah um and i and i think that's i don't
think it's just
you know uh you know just a man problem
but it
it was something that a lot of men seem
to have they they attach
too much importance to their jobs their
careers well
it's not that it's attached it's it's
it's genetic
it's hormonally supported it's genetic
men don't create children
all right men have men their priorities
are more centered around machines
and things that they do and things that
they can make that's really where
that's the difference and it has to do
with hormones it does
it's weird though because from a
biological standpoint
men can actually father children into
their 70s or 80s if they really wanted
to
yeah women cannot do that but you have
to look at what men are doing that
the men that are doing that would be
called patriarchs
yeah they're usually in a uh some
they're they're basically tribal
warlords they've conquered an area they
have a bunch of whole harem of wives
of different ages and uh yeah they can
you can keep them going
well in a situation like that they're on
they're they're on
natural trt they're constantly winning
again i'm talking about yeah because
there's stimulation yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah so it is biological
you cannot defy biology it's science
they want to [ __ ] erase it because
they don't like it it's not politically
correct
but that's what humans are we are what
we are
and i'm a i've embraced it and it's dumb
all right biology is dumb biology isn't
is it moral
once you start thinking that way it all
starts to make a lot of sense
it's real deep when i became shallow
yeah you mentioned that before yeah yeah
i used to be real deep and then i
realized that that would lead me astray
when i went back to being shallow it all
started to make a lot of sense
i can't be shallow yeah i'm gathering
superficial i'm not genetically perfect
be shallow and superficial i'm pulling
the biological card out
shallow and superficial always wins and
honestly it's like as much as i complain
about the way that i'm like
it's like i wouldn't if somebody came to
me and said hey do you want this
different personality i wouldn't do it
you know what i mean yeah in a weird way
i kind of like the way i am even though
it's like a lot of
even though it's a pain in the ass i'm a
pain in the ass to myself
you know what i'm saying so can we get
back to db cooper yeah it's time to get
back
we're almost done anyway no we're not no
look how much longer i have
oh [ __ ] yeah what yet
oh [ __ ] cause you're gonna talk about
the investigative [ __ ] too aren't you
well yeah well i'm just talking about
all the suspects all right so
uh as i said on the plane he left his
black clip-on tie
uh the tie clip that was on the tie and
also
uh some cigarette butts eight of them
actually
now you'd think that they you would be
able to get dna off the [ __ ] however the
cigarette butts were subsequently lost
sometime
in the 70s you know during the
investigation so
no good there um
but the interesting thing too was that
later on
in 1978
in late 1978 which if this was like
seven years after the hijacking
they actually found um this little it
was like a little card
and it had instructions on how to lower
the aft stairs of a 727
and they were actually able to determine
that this
had very likely blown off of the plane
like when he opened the stairs like to
jump out that it might have like been
swept off the plane
when he did that so they found that um
but it's like a hunter found that like
out in the [ __ ] forest
it was right by a logging road they
found it near castle rock
washington um and this was like
right around where the flight path would
have been so they assumed that it
probably came off of that plane so they
did find
something that they're pretty sure came
off of that airplane
i don't know i gotta say something what
uh grab this guy in that
comment section we went to high school
together he was a cop
all right he's been off the force for a
while
he says the cops usually die within five
years after retiring he said he's only
got three years left until the endless
sleep
tell you dad go get your [ __ ] go get
your levels checked get on trt
you'll feel a lot better you'll feel a
lot better i have to give him a shot
every week yeah you'll feel a lot better
right now yes starting to kick in now
i've been a fit my positivity
got better pretty much instantly but i'm
just now starting to feel it
coming in it'll plateau out in another
three weeks and just run it like that
to go ahead and [ __ ] take care of
yourself man i mean
and another thing that i that i realized
is that i feel like you drop
weight fast too well
dudes always yeah his way to just kind
of go back to an earlier state
you know women's bodies just want to
hang on to fat no
you might you might need it for baby
yeah even though you're old
your trt get back in the [ __ ] gym man
don't be a [ __ ] loser dude
drop all that weight better you'll get
better [ __ ] cardiovascular you'll
feel better
[ __ ] you'll be like like it was back
when we were at trenton high and [ __ ]
you'd be like
[ __ ] yeah for me she walks by now and
i'm going i look at that ass it's like
[ __ ] heat-seeking
damn she tried to get out of the bed i
said come here come here remember that
that morning yeah i woke up man i was
[ __ ] i was feeling good are you going
just now i got i got a gun and says no
no
no no no no bring that over well i was
like dude
it just took me a long time to extricate
because i let her go though she was like
busy
pokey falls asleep like right she had
fallen asleep like right here
i was trying to hit man i know that's
okay
[ __ ] was [ __ ] starting to come back
like the devil well i was awake for a
long time and then i was kind of like
then pookie was there and i kept waiting
for her to wake up and move but then she
didn't
because i i'm such a i hate to disturb
her
i know she'd have probably care or
she'll forget about it
but it's like she sometimes she'll like
to sleep right here and she's all
stretched out and everything and i'm
just like oh look at her she's so cute
and it's like
i'm like [ __ ] man now i can't get out of
bed so
i had just maneuvered my like i kind of
scooted down the bed and like i kind of
got out around her
and i was like okay i'm just gonna go to
the bathroom and put my you know
exercise clothes on would go for my hike
i could put my backpack on and [ __ ]
and like as soon as i had maneuvered out
of the bed and it took like a really
long time so i didn't wake pookie up
and then like tom grabs my arm hey don't
go anywhere i was just kind of like god
damn it i just got the [ __ ] out of here
i was trying not to wake pookie up leave
me alone so you know it was like that
um all right
so where the [ __ ] was that okay so this
is
one okay so this part right here that
we're getting to
probably one of the most famous aspects
of the case and one of the things that
really if anything kind of deepened the
mystery like you would think oh hey we
found a clue and now we're going to
figure some [ __ ] out but this just like
made everything more
weird and you know and and like we're
never gonna solve it
so 1980 nine years
well almost nine years because it was
kind of early in 1980 so it was like
eight and a half years more like
so so it was 1980 and it was after after
the hijacking
there's this eight-year-old kid named
brian ingram
and he's uh on a little vacation with
his family
uh on the columbia river and they're at
this kind of beach
front sort of place it's called tina bar
i don't know why it's called that um
about nine miles
uh downstream from vancouver washington
and he was kind of scraping around in
the dirt um
he was gonna build a campfire and he
found
three packets of money
and the serial numbers on this money
corresponded
to the ransom money
now this wasn't all the money obviously
it was just like a small portion of it
now the money itself
was kind of disintegrated but the rubber
bands
were still intact which kind of
significant
so this was two packets of 120 dollar
bills each and a third packet of 90
which means that
somebody had taken
one bill i guess or 10 bills rather
out of one of the packets before they
ended up
where they ended up i'm not really sure
how that happened
now so this so these particular bills
this is kind of interesting because
even though the bills were kind of
disintegrated and suggested
that perhaps the money had been dropped
in the river
and it just washed up at this particular
place
some experts that looked into it were
kind of like well
if the money had been in the water
because this was like
almost nine years later right they're
like if the money had been in the water
that long or if it had been
there that long the rubber bands would
have disintegrated also but they didn't
so it's so there's always i don't know
there's always like something kind of
nebulous about all the all the [ __ ]
clues that are found in this i'm talking
about the money that they found
yeah later on yeah money okay i'm gonna
let you talk about the money
yeah so so there's a lot of things so
and it's
almost impossible because some experts
have said
you know oh the packets just you know
they fell in the water they washed up
but then some of them said no it looked
like it had deliberately been buried
because of the way that the
you know kind of the ground was or
whatever and
and the fact that like i said the rubber
bands weren't disintegrated which they
would have if they'd been in the water
that long because like i said it's been
almost nine years since the hijacking
that's how long it took for this money
to be found so they're like well
obviously it couldn't have been in the
water
for that long and some experts said that
it couldn't have gone into the water any
earlier than 1974
which was three years after the
hijacking so they don't know
if db cooper if you know if he
died and then somebody just found this
money and buried it there for some
reason
or if it washed up a long time ago and
it just somehow doesn't
look like it washed up a long time ago i
don't know so there's like a lot of
really kind of like unclear details
about the [ __ ]
it could kind of go either way just like
pretty much every other [ __ ]
fact in this case so uh
as of this as far as anybody knows this
is the only portion of the ransom money
that has ever turned up anywhere
um as i said they have all the serial
numbers of all the other 20
bills that they gave to him and as far
as anyone knows
none of the other ones have ever turned
up anyplace
um so the kid uh brian ingram
his family they actually ended up
selling some of the bills
uh at an auction for 37 thousand dollars
in 2008 because hey that's some famous
[ __ ]
you know i don't i don't i don't
begrudge him that
um they also found
uh 2017 i guess there was some uh
kind of amateur investigators kind of
poking around the area because like i
said
you have to think the area where they
think that his drop zone was
not only has the fbi local police you
know
authorities looked all through that
place everybody's so interested in the
db cooper case that they've had a bunch
of like
volunteers going through that [ __ ] too
and no one so far has found anything
other than that money
no one has really found anything however
in 2017
there were some kind of amateur sleuths
and they thought
that they found something that they
described
as a parachute strap that was really
really old
um and then they said they found like a
piece of foam that looked like it was
from the backpack he was wearing but as
far as i know that's
that hasn't been confirmed so i don't
know it just might be random [ __ ] that
was out there
so in 2007
the fbi came out and said that they had
found
or they had obtained a partial dna
profile
from the tie that they found
which belonged to db cooper now
it should be said and the fbi has
acknowledged this they're like now we
did find the dna on the tie
but that's not to say that that is
that the dna necessarily came from him
you know what i mean it's likely that it
probably did but it could have come from
somewhere else there's really no way of
knowing
so they did find like three separate
samples
um however so far this is not matched
with any
particular person but they do have dna
on file or at least a partial dna
profile they also um
put out and this was in 2007 as i said
um a bunch of evidence that they hadn't
previously released to the public um
they
actually released his uh dan cooper's
original plane ticket
so you know people could look at it um
and some other
like uh composite sketches and [ __ ] like
that
which that which hadn't uh been released
to the public before
and they also said and as far as i know
this
information was not disclosed prior to
2007
they also said that two of the primary
parachutes that they had given
to dan cooper um
that he had chosen the older one
rather than the newer one which was like
better
it was like a sport parachute and it was
like just more technically
advanced i guess um they speculated that
he might have chosen the older one
because it was a model that he was more
familiar with
um rather than kind of the new fancy one
he's maybe he's just like oh i don't
have time to like figure this [ __ ] out
right now this is like newfangled [ __ ] i
don't know
that's just like some speculation
and from the two reserve parachutes that
they gave him he selected the one that
was a dummy
now this was not an actual parachute
this was one that had an inoperative rip
cord
they used it for um you know training
you know
now the fbi says or whoever gave him the
parachutes
they said that they didn't intend to
give him a dummy parachute because like
i said we were talking about that
earlier where
dan cooper was afraid that somebody that
they would give him some like
[ __ ] up parachutes and so that's maybe
why he was checking that out definitely
but the fbi said well the parachutes
that we gave him the one was a dummy but
we didn't intend for it to be a dummy
they got it from like a
a parachute like a skydiving school is
that the one he threw out
i don't know i don't know that was one
of the ones that he took with him though
oh [ __ ] he may have been wearing that
one well that that's what some people
have speculated that maybe he was
wearing but although you'd think that if
he knew anything about anything that he
would know that that was a dummy
kind of like sewed shot maybe he
checked one and said yeah this is a good
parachute put the dummy on
thinking that they were the same jumped
out that could be your answer right
there well i thought about that too but
they did say they're like look he
seemed like he knew enough about
parachuting and about aircraft and
everything
because the dummy parachute it doesn't
look like
the other pair it kind of had some
markings on it that says hey this isn't
an operable parachute please don't use
this one
because it's just for training purposes
maybe he threw that out the back
maybe he did it's because they said you
know he seemed like it was pretty well
planned and he
kind of knew his [ __ ] so you'd think
that he would know that that one wasn't
usable
because i thought that too he was moving
fast baby
i don't know i wasn't paying attention
to the little details
that's that could be a possible answer
to this
i thought about that too people put that
dummy on he didn't notice that it said
this is a dummy
that it's like hey don't use this one to
jump out of the plane yeah check the
other one says yeah because it's not
gonna work parachutes are real and then
you grab the dummy put them on
it's possible it's possible that's one
possibility
um something else this is also very
interesting i actually hadn't heard this
because i haven't been keeping up
hadn't been keeping up with this case uh
you know for the past several decades
like i said the last thing i saw about
it was unsolved mysteries that was a
long time ago
march 2009 the fbi came out and said
that um something that they found
uh on the tie
it wasn't just the dna which like i said
didn't match to anyone that they know of
yet
but they did do like an electron
microscope like on the tie
and they found all these little
particles on the tie
they found particles of bismuth and
aluminum
lycopodium spores uh
unalloyed titanium and they said this
was like some
it's you know fairly common nowadays but
back in 1971 this was pretty uncommon
so they think that maybe
dan cooper whoever he was um that this
was his tie
and that he wore it to work and that
maybe he worked somewhere
um that did metal fabrication or
a chemical company um some people have
speculated that maybe he worked at
boeing
because they would have used these
particular chemicals because there
wasn't a lot of different companies that
would have used these particular
chemicals at the time so much so that it
would infuse into the tie
you know what i mean so uh some people
have speculated that maybe he was like
some kind of manager or worked in
uh worked in that field it was like you
know aircraft
railroad anything like that or you know
chemicals anything like that
um because that just it wasn't a very
common like chemical that you would see
uh in 1971 so they think maybe he was a
chemist
you know had something to do with
metallurgy or as i said maybe perhaps
worked at uh
boeing something like that um
so let's talk about uh
some of the theories about what happened
to this dude then we'll kind of get into
some of the subs
the suspects
so basically so what they're saying
dan cooper um he seemed to be pretty
familiar
with the seattle area they thought that
probably he was an air force
veteran or it seemed very likely that he
was
he did recognize tacoma
from the air and he did know where
mccord air force base was and how far
away it was from where they were flying
which um seemed like something that
probably a civilian wouldn't know
what were you gonna say i'm gonna say
there's got their [ __ ] jump into some
conclusions there just because he knew
what the lay of the land
didn't make him air force most guys that
are in the air force are ground crew
they
don't even get an aircraft that much all
right
parachuting is not really an air force
thing they got a couple special ops
units that do it
like rescue type teams rescuing down
pilots
but no man [ __ ] parachuting is a
[ __ ]
army thing that's the us army airborne
82nd airborne division does it
173rd does it the re uh the ranger
regiments do it sf
does it or special forces they do it
that's an
army thing all right i just unless he
went to some kind of a
class or a school afterwards and did
some skydiving training
right that's the only thing you could
get skydiving training
it was more rare in 71 you know but it
was there
that kind of [ __ ] really was more common
in california in the 70s
you know what i mean like if you want to
be a skydiver in the 70s where would you
go
california yeah that's where the hang
gliders were too
at that time so i don't think he's air
force i think he's army
well they thought that he had military
sure they use the military veterans yeah
but i think he's army
mango's asking did they do a passenger
account when the plane landed still have
a feeling he never got off the craft he
did though because
um they let all the passengers off
because the plane landed
after he said he had a bomb plane landed
at seattle tacoma
they let all the passengers off and then
he
was still on the plane with four crew
members and they all saw him
on the plane like when it took back off
so they let all the passengers off but
he was still on the plane they saw him
another thing that makes you think he
was army
is because he's awful confident and not
worrying about what he's gonna do when
he's getting on
getting on the ground you know
airborne infantry or ranger he's going
to be [ __ ] proud about getting on the
ground he's thinking that's normal he's
not worried about that
you know what i mean an air force guy
would have taken more precautions to
just jump out of a [ __ ] plane
and land to do a plf out in the middle
of the woods and then walk his way back
to civilization
where you're talking about maybe a 20 20
or 30 mile walk
probably you know
this is something army dude would
attempt that's just what i'm saying
yeah well like i said they're pretty
sure that he was military yeah like
was ex-military some kind of airborne
infantry
he's gonna say yeah be on the ground be
fine you know yes he has confidence
yeah i think he died on impact that's
what i think happened well i think he
did too but like i said we haven't even
got into the suspects yet so don't like
jumping
but um yeah so another thing i want to
do and i mentioned this earlier
but it seems that he knew enough to pick
uh a 727 uh because
of all the commercial airliners it was
not only the one that was
you know the relatively the easiest to
jump out of with
you know minimal risk of harm uh you
know just because of the way that it was
situated
and because it had uh an aft air stare
like in the back where you could jump
out and not
risk too much like you know running into
the fuselage or the engines or anything
like that
but it also had um a single point
fueling
capacity which you could uh refuel
all the tanks from one spot
which was unusual for the time it was
also one of the
few if not the only commercial jet
airliner
that could maintain
such a low speed and low altitude
without stalling
which he seemed to know as well he also
knew to put the um
the airline the flaps on the wings to 15
degrees which
as far as i know was at the time um
unique to that particular aircraft so he
did seem to know
about the aircraft you know that
particular aircraft he had done a lot of
research on it
you know and the things that it could do
that other commercial airliners weren't
necessarily doing
um another interesting thing too is i
found this interesting maybe this is
where he got his
pseudonym from uh
there was some speculation going around
among authorities that he might have
gotten his alias
there was a comic book series from the
1970s
and the name of the hero in it
was dan cooper and he was a royal
canadian air force test pilot
and one of the even one of the covers
like i've seen one of the covers online
it's did like a dude jumping out of a
plane with like the suit and everything
on
so he saw that so yeah well but the
interesting thing
is that this comic book series is
belgian
and it's french language it was never
translated into english and it was never
sold in the u.s
it was sold in canada however um so
that's where some more speculation came
from that maybe he was canadian
because of the thing that he said about
american currency and stuff like that
like the fact that he made specifically
and the fact that he may have maybe
taken his alias from this particular
comic book which like i said was not
sold in the us at that time
and was not even translated into english
at that time so
it could be it it was for sale in canada
so maybe he had seen it there
was a fan of it yeah it's a good theory
well like it seems very weird that
it was a pretty popular comic book in
belgium and i guess in like
french-speaking parts of
uh canada as well and it seems very
weird that there was like a dude and he
was like a test pilot named dan cooper
who was like and on the cover yeah
i mean that might be a total coincidence
could be that he just saw the cover of
that somewhere in his travels
yeah that's possible and and he's like
and just remembered it and somebody said
that's dad cooper he said look at that
dude jumping out
you know it might have been something
that simple that's like some heist i
want to pull yeah
that's the name i'm going to use yeah
something like that yeah seriously
but okay so the thing about it though is
that
um even though like we were talking
about before it does seem like he
planned a lot of the early [ __ ] about
this like yeah
you know i'm gonna wear dark glasses i'm
gonna like say i have a bomb
you know he knew all the [ __ ] about the
plane and everything but then once he
jumped out
it seemed like he didn't really plan it
that well i don't really know
so and also they were like he must have
known
because as sarah ann mentioned earlier
it's like since the lindbergh kidnapping
which when the [ __ ] was that in the 30s
right like ever since that happened
um you know the authorities kept track
of the serial numbers of the bills
to pay ransom money so he must have
known
that they would keep track of the serial
numbers of the money that they were
going to give him so even if he got the
money
how did he think he was gonna spend it
you know what i mean
because like they would be looking for
him well brad said
this he said why would a guy go to
mexico
if you're trying to get back to canada i
don't know well it could be that he may
be from canada and he's trying to get as
far away from canada as possible
that might be another thing too i mean
there could be a lot of reasons
why he was going guy may not want
nothing to do with canada anymore well
and like i said
canada has extradition with the us and
mexico doesn't
or or it didn't at that time i don't
think there's a possibility he could be
canadian
but he would be canadian airborne he'd
be canadian infantry
yeah now um
oh mike says well maybe he might be some
kind of special forces i don't know that
acronym it's probably something like
sp uh something kind of like air force
special operations
something or other i don't know that the
thing is though is that when you're
talking about guys that [ __ ]
do halo which is high altitude low
opening jumps
or any kind of combat jump if
statistically it's going to be army it's
going to be the 82nd airborne division
because they're the most numerous all
those other units are tiny
which means it's less likely that that
was
that he would be from a unit like that
and another thing that would make it
less likely
is that those little tiny special
operations air force units and and
and army units when those guys get out
they don't have any problem making a
hundred thousand dollars a year in these
bucket security companies what the [ __ ]
they need to rob a
damn plane for they don't need that
they're
they make money and also they're lifers
they're in until they're about 40 and
then when they get out they just go into
the damn military industrial complex
and continue to make even more money
they're not robbers
i mean like i said even though i kind of
admire the ballsiness of this heist i'm
you know i i i kind of have a lot of
admiration for people that as long as i
don't kill anybody
um i have an admiration for people that
pull off these really like audacious
heists you know
yeah this is not a written but yeah well
the actually the fbi
um they probably thought this dude was
probably like super desperate for money
yeah this is not a rich guy this is a
[ __ ] working class dude
yeah all right he's intelligent though
and he's got an experience in this kind
of stuff
so where what are we talking about we're
talking about the 82nd airborne division
that's what we're talking about there's
lots of them they're all working class
they have the requisites to do this
mission especially if they have the
willpower
and he's 40 so he's not a kid yeah
maybe mid-40s maybe mid-40s so yeah he
could do it
maybe this was his like last horizon i'm
ready to retire
yeah yeah well because like i said 200
000 it's a lot of money but it's
was even way more it was more than a
million dollars back then
you know the equivalent so you probably
i mean you pretty much would have been
set for life i don't think he made it
but at least he went out in a blaze of
glory
yeah it kind of makes me sad because i
kind of even though he's a criminal i
kind of wish that he did make it
but i'm i kind of subjected height
yeah i kind of suspect that he didn't
well you gotta load it this way he
wasn't stealing from an average
joe it's not like he's robbing from a
[ __ ] liquor store that's what i mean
it's like yeah that but yeah die
whatever i don't care but it's just
stealing from a big company yeah if
you're just stealing from a big company
or a bank yeah go for it yeah
you can get away with it if you're
willing if you're willing to do that
time do what you want to do
but if you're willing to [ __ ] jump
out of a [ __ ] plane
and you don't know where you're at
possibly get killed keep it
and then keep it spend 15 20 years
[ __ ] behind bars if you get caught
it's on you bro go ahead and do it keep
it it's a mad respect
i'm just saying yeah i don't i wouldn't
have the ball it's like
that's what i'm saying and i think we
were talking about that when we were
watching the movie too i said
i with these kind of like big heists
like this like
i'm fascinated by because i one of these
days i want to do a show about either
the
uh the isabella gardner museum heist or
there was like a really big heist in the
antwerp in like the diamond district and
the dude spent like two years
like planning the show like they
infiltrated like all the
companies like they had people working
there and like all these inside people
and it was like fascinating there was a
whole bunch of them
and if you are willing to put that much
[ __ ] work and effort and risk
into it i almost kind of feel like you
know what
just let him have it it what it's just
it's a bank
it's a bank it's a diamond cup they're
insured
it's still stealing it's against the law
that's not right that's not how you look
at it that they
are stealing from a corporation they're
gonna fight back i know they are but
it's like
it's not like you're just like stealing
a bread stealing a loaf of bread from
like a mom and pop yeah
there's there is a big difference in it
uh
it's a more of a professional thing
the problem it becomes it becomes uh it
goes from gray to black
when uh you start killing people who are
in your way well like i said
that's not good yeah obviously the guys
that are [ __ ]
that actually are really good at this
kind of [ __ ] will kill a [ __ ]
with a heartbeat
to get in the way and uh
i'm not really big into killing people
for money especially people that are not
a threat
to you i don't have any problem if
somebody's trying to kill me or it's
another soldier or
we're in a fight over some [ __ ] kind
of [ __ ] dominance over
some political thing or whatever and
there's state sanctioning behind it or
you're
what the founding father of a new
[ __ ] country in a damn revolution
that's [ __ ] on the table that's on
the menu history is like that
people are like that going out [ __ ]
blowing some [ __ ]
chicks head off to get her purse
no you're [ __ ] scum you're [ __ ]
well yeah like i said
if yeah like okay here's another thing
[ __ ] emel and the other guy at the
north hollywood [ __ ] shooting
where they had those [ __ ] machine
guns were robbing the banks and they
were fighting the entire lapd
they didn't kill any of them but they
were kind of trying to
all right all right no you're gonna kill
a cop
[ __ ] over some money i mean that
dude's got a family too i mean you're a
[ __ ] skunk well that's right
yeah that's what i'm saying it's like
the people that are like look it's just
like a dude driving an armored car so
like you're just like a working glass
like the work of stitches
like they got kids and a wife and bags
of money or a husband or whatever it's
like
your [ __ ] skull but but yeah like i
said
that's why i was like so into like these
like diamond heist guys and like art
heists and stuff
their whole thing is they don't really
want to hurt anybody
but so they just plant it so they don't
have to
like they have this big elaborate plant
it's like look we're gonna like
infiltrate they have molds in there that
like work
let me give a shout out just because
you're talking about the diamond heist
you guys gotta see the [ __ ] movie
called uncut gems
all right that was [ __ ] it was a adam
sandler movie of all things
but he does this badass gangster movie
and hollywood hated it because they
didn't like the [ __ ] stereotypes and
[ __ ]
he plays and it was written it was based
around a real
[ __ ] dude who wrote a book about his
dad his dad was a jewish dude working
down the diamond district of [ __ ]
new york involved in all these with all
these other italian and irish type
gangsters
in the diamond industry making money off
selling
[ __ ] bling to [ __ ] rap stars and
basketball stars
called uncut gems it's a [ __ ]
masterpiece yeah it was really good but
[ __ ] really good movie it was one of
the most time i've never been that
anxious watching a movie
that movie will twist you up in a
[ __ ] it might be really really
actually just a [ __ ]
jewish gangster playing unheard of games
with other people's money
yeah you're just on the edge of your
seat stealing money to papa
to hawk other people's [ __ ] to get money
up upon
it to bet it on a game to have uh he
just had this [ __ ] money tied up into
so many [ __ ]
that that was his masterpiece to bet on
this [ __ ]
baseball basketball game it was just and
this movie was just [ __ ]
uncut gems was up for an academy award
yeah it was just it didn't win but it
was
it was actually nominated that movie is
[ __ ] um one of the best gangster
movies of all times
somebody somebody asked um did they find
any of the money
they did i just mentioned earlier they
did find a little bit of the money i
think they found um
a couple hundred of the 20 bills like
kind of buried in a packet like a little
boy found it
in 1980 like nine years after almost
nine years after the
heist but so far none of the other money
has turned up
uh somebody asked too do we know what
altitude the plane was flying at i
believe it was ten thousand feet
because he did ask them this was one of
the reasons that he
supposedly like chose the boeing 727
because it was one of the few commercial
airliners
that could fly at that low in altitude
and could fly
at a low speed without stalling so he uh
basically when the plane took back off
like after it landed he
let all the passengers off he said okay
i want you to fly at 10 000 feet and i
want you to fly as slow as you can go
without stalling
um because like i said he was planning
on jumping out so i believe it was about
ten thousand feet hold on one second
they're talking about that movie and
tina says uncle james is great and then
somebody said i can't stand
adam sandler this is not an adam sandler
movie like you know it
sandler [ __ ] does a job in this movie
he's just
he plays this [ __ ] jewish gangster
that
is he knocks it out of the [ __ ] park
i can understand
sandler movies can get on your [ __ ]
this is not that movie yeah like i can't
stand his comedies
but he's actually a good actor when he's
not
being adam's antler yeah he's not being
that adam
sandler he's [ __ ] doing this this
role it's [ __ ] great
i gotta buy that movie on blu-ray i want
to see that again
yeah we saw it in the theater actually
and like i said i've never been so
other than hereditary i've never been so
[ __ ] anxious in a [ __ ] movie
theater before
it's very different but it's up there
with say like goodfellas
like that yeah at that level yeah
i had a bunch of undertones in it about
spiritualism
and [ __ ] and and being able to [ __ ]
have a soul
it's pretty cool you'll see it yeah
yeah so all right so i think my drink's
empty
yeah all right
so uh at this point like i said there's
a couple different factions
uh so you have some kind of authorities
that are like
well um you know there it's totally
possible he could have made it he could
have jumped out of the wood like
they kind of were like okay well he
obviously knew what he was doing he
asked for the particular parachutes he
knew
uh he seemed to know kind of the area he
knew the terrain he knew the flight path
um he knew about the parachutes he knew
about the aircraft
he knew like a lot of the technical
specs um
and he was dressed in a manner that
maybe
maybe he could have jumped out of the
plane and made his way to a road
and someone could have picked him up and
then he could have just like disappeared
they did note that it was a holiday
weekend as i said he did this on the
day before thanksgiving uh because you
know
that would have been in the u.s uh
four-day weekend thursday friday
saturday sunday
and they're like you know had he made it
uh it's totally thank you it's totally
possible
that he could have like pulled the heist
off he could have got somebody pick him
up and gone back and then just gone back
to work on monday like nothing happened
and nobody would know any different
however uh the fbi a little bit
skeptical of this they're kind of saying
well we're we are acknowledging that he
does
seem to have some knowledge of skydiving
he does seem to know
about that aircraft he did seem to know
the terrain and everything like that
however
it did seem really really stupid
to jump out of a plane
uh at the altitude the speed they were
going he wasn't dressed for the weather
i mean pretty much all he had on was
like a white dress shirt and pants
uh and kind of like an overcoat it was
late november
in like the pacific northwest it was
really really cold
uh the weather was really really shitty
uh the visibility was almost
zero he had really no idea
where he was jumping out at it's it's
like not only was it really really dark
there was also
a lot of really thick cloud cover so
they're saying when he jumped out of the
plane
he wouldn't have known where he was
going uh the parachutes that he took
with him were not steerable
as in you kind of ended up where you
ended up you couldn't be like hey i'm
gonna go over here so i don't like get
impaled on that tree
uh so there was that so i don't know so
the fbi are kind of thinking it's like
yeah he did have some knowledge but
maybe not as much knowledge as people
thought that he did
like back in the 70s maybe he wasn't
quite the genius
that everyone thought he was because
only an idiot would have jumped out in
those conditions
is what they're saying because it was
really really cool it was like what was
like 15 degrees or something like that
like up where they were
and he wasn't dressed for it he just
held like a dress shirt and pants yeah
and a little bit of an overcoat and that
was it
he didn't have and a good chance you
could land in the water exactly
so so it's like it's very possible even
if he did land he might have died of
hypothermia for christ
like before he got anywhere so there's
like all kind of different uh
scenarios um as to what
could have happened and honestly a lot
of the fbi uh
dudes said that you know it's it's
possible that he never even opened the
shoot that he just like jumped out
thought and
maybe it was the dummy shoot like you
said maybe it was the other one maybe
it's an open
and maybe he's just like [ __ ]
splattered on the ground and like nobody
[ __ ] found him there's that 50
chance he put that dummy actually maybe
greater because he was never found
how much of a bet it was a 60 to 70
chance that he had that dummy shoot on
pulling it that's kind of what i thought
and he's like oh [ __ ] i was like
wouldn't that be shitty
and even though i don't know if the if
the authorities did that on purpose they
said they didn't
but i don't know
[ __ ] [ __ ] bus open money [ __ ] bag
goes open
later on some of that gets washed
downstream and they find the money a
couple miles away
up on the bank silt covered it up
they're saying it was buried i don't
believe it was buried
well that's the thing you can't really
tell now the only thing that's weird
about that though was that 10 of the 20
bills were missing from the pack but uh
but the
other packs were like all together still
so they thought that was really strange
that you know they were together that
they were together
because they're like look if his body
and all the money and [ __ ] like that had
fallen into the river
and been washed up to where the kid
found it maybe it
should have been separated it's like it
seemed weird that there were three
packets of it like together and that
some of the bills were missing
he was injured so he buried some of it
to lighten his load but
that's a possibility and he walked out
and then got
elsewhere and then like animals ate him
and [ __ ] yeah i mean
yeah that could be like maybe he
survived the fall but
he didn't make it if he had made it he'd
gone back for that money
you would think or he'd got caught
spending that money
i mean yeah the fact that i mean you
would have done it again
yeah well like i said i'll get into that
when we talk about
we talk about like some of the suspects
because yeah
well that's the thing it's that's one of
the things that bothers me is that
even though it's weird that the money
was found like some of the money was
found where it was found then it looked
like
you know could it have washed up there
yeah but like the way it was found
was like unlikely and the fact that some
of the bills were missing like someone
had taken them
i don't really know like i said no one
even knows whether db cooper was the one
that
put them there maybe somebody else found
them like in the interim because it was
like several years later right
so anything could have happened in the
meantime um
but the fact that none of the other
money has turned up
suspicious that is very suspicious to me
i mean because you would think
i mean unless he found some way of
[ __ ] laundering that [ __ ]
like really really effectively well he
did have plans maybe he had a plan to
launder it
you would think because like i said ever
since the 30s people knew that they
could track
the serial numbers so if you were gonna
if you were gonna take that amount of
money you would have to have some plan
afterwards like how you're gonna spend
it because you wouldn't be able to spend
it they would catch you
and indeed like the people that did
copycat [ __ ]
similar to what he did like after he did
it they caught all those people like
immediately
the money never resurfaced so that tells
me he died
that's that i kind of suspect he
probably did too like i said i'm not
sure
i don't know but um let's get into some
of the suspects though because
this shit's like [ __ ] fascinating so
obviously i can't cover them all because
there's hundreds
maybe even you know close to a thousand
that they've looked into over the years
but these are the ones that are kind of
like the most
talked about the most serious ones the
you know the ones that have the most
uh to kind of recommend them i guess
so the first one let's talk about this
dude named kenneth christensen
now what happened with this one how this
dude came to light so this didn't happen
until 2003.
so there's this dude in minnesota named
lyle christensen and he saw
a documentary about the db cooper
hijacking
and it came to his mind that his brother
kenneth who by this point was dead he
had died in 1994
uh was actually d.b cooper crashed again
crashed again you did
just wait wait see if it comes back
because it's still running here
i think it's still running
should i just keep talking just keep
talking yeah you guys can you guys hear
us
come on come on come on you can do it
although i i don't think this has ever
like come back
after this has happened i can see it i
can see us talking
yeah yeah i can't see it it's
just it's it's scaring me let's see what
this is all about
yeah see yeah it's doing doing that it's
doing
that she's doing it i hit the damn mouse
and then also we
jump forward a little bit